when you're talking about marriage you
can display the points but if you say
was it possibility point you even more
probability to get one solution right
now but that is almost like income it's
also assumed that you will always get
with it yes true yes then some and yes
yes very true well you know there used
to be before the divorce laws were
really liberalized there were you could
sue for irreconcilable differences and
and sometimes people do find themselves
in that situation it's like one person
wants children and the other person
doesn't it's like that's a tough one
it's a tough one to negotiate so I'm
certainly not saying that just because
you lock yourself into a like two cats
in a barrel that that will make you
solve your problems because problems are
hard to solve and sometimes you can't
solve them I was just pointing out what
the cost of leaving the back door Oh
what the cost of leaving the back door
open is and it's a big cost and you know
one of the things I see too is that
people's identities fragment
increasingly across time you know one of
the things that you have as you age is
something like the continuity of your
life you know you you have someone that
you're with you've tied your story
together with theirs you have children
maybe they have children it's like
there's this continual payoff so to
speak in quality that you obtain from
staying within that frame and you can
jump out of that and I suppose to some
degree that that provides freedom but it
isn't obvious to me that it does that
for people they usually that was the
things with
it's my bloody email no but but but it's
also the case that sequential
relationships are unlikely to be that so
look I'm not a not make I'm definitely
not making a utopian case for marriage
so again I would like to give you a verb
with from you because it'd be really
interesting right it is top point but at
the same time I think there are
creations that are regional quality
young and we keep that the case then in
1501 cannot be good
yeah well that's that's definitely the
alternative argument and of course there
are strong things to be said on both
sides but
see there's some additional problems
with divorce that people don't really
grasp when they're young like the idea
that you can be divorced once you have
children that's kind of a stupid idea
because you can't you can you can you
can find a limited substitute for your
initial freedom but if you if you have
kids and you try to get divorced the
probability that that's going to
demolish your life is very very high
first of all it's incredibly expensive
so one or both of you is going to come
out of that poor and your market value
has declined let's say you're the woman
who takes the kids your market value has
declined radically you're going to be
poorer the man is just as screwed
because he is now an indentured servant
and there's no escape from it so it's an
it's not so bad if you can negotiate a
peaceful separation and some people can
but lots of times if you have a terrible
relationship it's not like negotiating a
peaceful separation is all that easy but
if you're at each other's throats good
luck to you I think it's roughly
equivalent to having non fatal cancer it
is not pleasant it's a 10-year process
15 year process will cost you two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
it'll tear a big chunk out of your life
and also it will really disrupt your
relationship with your kids and you know
you bring kids into a stepparent family
they do not do as well step parents are
not as good parents as biological
parents and the data on that is clear
now obviously there are exceptions
because there are terrible biological
parents and there are wonderful step
parents but if you look in aggregate
it's not that easy to care for children
you need everything you can binding you
to them and if there's someone else's
children mostly they get in the way of
the person that you love right well if
I'm let's say you have a child I'll be
right out let's say you have a child and
I want to go out with you every second
you spend with that child is the second
you don't spend with me and and there's
going to be a price for that I'm not
going to be happy about that and and if
I have a child you're going to feel
exactly the same way you might say well
no I love children it's like yeah yeah
sure sure you do I doubt it
you might love your child and and you
know it's pretty specific the way that
people love children so and the rate of
abuse for kids in stepparent families is
way higher than it is in biological
families
there's not even any comparison so
anyways